thank you rachel thanks everybody for
coming
as rachel mentioned lines are open at
any time we want to get your questions
answered and they can be as rachel
mentioned anonymous or not
so let me kind of switch gears here
and get to my slides okay
all right i will share some links to get
my resources and everything in a moment
as well
but if you want to let me know at the
beginning again we want to make this as
conversational as possible so let me
know what what brought you here today
what have you tried what's worked what's
not worked
i don't have all the answers on this
but we're all helping each other so
let us know
and again we want to and there will be
an announcement later to help you
continue on in this path it's not the
easiest thing to get a team who's used
to using excel to kind of think
the art of the possible and using r and
see how possible it is
i hope this presentation shows you how
easy it is
and then we can take you to that next
level to actually see that through to
your organization
okay so just for a little cold open i
want to really get it out of your head
that r is necessarily harder than excel
i think that's the word on the street
you do have to code it but you have to
code a lot of things in excel as well so
i'm not sure that that's the best
thing to think about it as being
necessarily harder i've got a few other
case studies like this and then we're
going to move into a short demo and then
we'll go uh for questions i've also got
a couple of books to give away so make
sure that you stick around and you may
get a copy of my book advancing in
analytics if you don't want a copy
you get a consolation prize you can read
it for free
i will give you a link to do that so
everybody's a winner with the book
okay
let's say you want to visualize a bunch
of variables
this is how i see you would do it now
again i could be wrong with these
examples where i'm showing excel and r
and how you do something so let me know
if there's another way because there's
almost always another way in excel or r
but this is how i would do it let's say
you know i have a bunch of variables in
my data set and i want to see the
relationships between all of them
okay this would be a lot of code in in
excel right
that's a lot
this is literally three lines in r okay
and this is a pretty nice thing to have
you know you have data you want to
visualize it that's not a bad idea
a lot easier to do an r okay
so we're going to do a few more examples
of that but again just to give you a
sense of what we're going to do really
understanding how excel and r fit
together in the analytics stack i'm not
going to tell you to get rid of excel
i'm not going to tell you that excel
sucks i'm not going to spread any lies
about excel that often happen when
people try to push other tools
we're going to introduce r for you kind
of see how all these tools fit together
uh hopefully you'll have fun
i hope you're telling that i'm having
fun and i think rachel is too we'll see
you know try to get everybody else on
board and then maybe like i said win a
book or if you don't want a book you can
get the link and read it for free so
we're all winners on that
okay
the first link is going to be here now
if you want to follow along and i'll put
this in
the chat as well and then if there's any
place
that
should be shared also we can we can get
that circulated but this is going to
have all the resources and everything
now i'm aware that a lot of people may
be coming to this for the first time in
r they don't have it installed they
can't get it installed because they're
at work etc uh just click this link you
can follow along and that will run it'll
take a few minutes but you'll be able to
run everything that we're doing on the
cloud
and then when you read the book you'll
learn how to download it uh and then
we'll help you make the case to get it
installed at work hopefully okay so if
there are any questions there let me
know
uh i'm gonna go back to the slides and
and we'll keep going here
and questions are welcome at any time
okay i'm going to skip this slide this
is from the book just to situate all the
various parts of excel again i'm telling
you that
don't don't uninstall excel if you're
here that's not my takeaway
by any means all right
so where's are going to help you
now these are some things and if you've
used r before if you're an excel user i
just kind of uh boiled this down into a
few categories of tasks that i find
really helpful if you're an excel user
where r could help now the first thing
i'm going to mention is power query it's
kind of the elephant in the room that's
the first question i often get
if you're using power query you're not
in excel let us know but
power query is a data preparation data
transformation tool in excel and it can
do a lot of the things that r can do to
be honest it can build a reproducible
workflow it can work with big data so
this thing about oh you can't do a
million rows in excel past that if
you're using power query that's not
necessarily true this is not an excel
course per se but just to know that
power query does exist but there are
still things that are helpful
uh with excel so like data
visualizations we saw you have a bunch
of variables you want to visualize them
you want to iterate on that
r is going to help you there anything i
found that we're working with groups
where you have some data and you want to
go through group by group and do some
kind of trans uh complex transformation
think about r for that again window
functions kind of related to that
cumulative averages uh lagging variables
leading variables
you're going to see some examples where
where power query is kind of challenging
for that um and then anything having to
do with randomization uh excel i
recently learned that excel's um
random number generator is proprietary
intentionally they they have not shared
how the random numbers are actually
randomly generated for
a reason and that has proprietary
benefits but if you try to make your
workflow reproducible that might not be
a good thing if you want to seed your
random data so those are just a few a
few things that that would be helpful so
again just to make this really concrete
i'm going to create an index column by
group now again if you have another way
to do this in excel let me know this is
the way that i found it's a lot of code
it can't even fit on the slide
uh our
four four lines of code and it's pretty
readable too right uh we're grouping by
something we're gonna take an index
number that looks like it's based on the
row uh then where i'm gonna print the
head of it i guess that's the first few
rows right so
it's pretty english sounding this is i
don't know i guess it's english but i
don't know what decompress binary is
what the heck is that
so again yeah it's not necessarily
easier uh creating a lag variable
another one you actually have to create
your own custom function to do this as
far as i know and power query
in our somebody's already made that
function for you that's another thing we
have packages in our they're they're
like apps somebody's built a package and
you can use it and it's bundled the code
and then that means that all i have to
do is say oh i want a lagged variable
and you're seeing that these are all
kind of the same pattern right i mean
the whole idea with what we're doing
here in r is that these are really
supposed to be predictable and when
you're going to do something it should
follow kind of the same paradigm where
as you're seeing in excel we're kind of
we've been all over the place already
right we're using vba if you remember
to do uh
back here there's that and then we
wanted to do
uh this and that looks a little
different and now this is a little
different so everything
nothing's really
kind of syntactically matching and
that's really a big thing of ours
specifically with the tidy verse talk
about everything's kind of meant to be
interchangeable interchangeable parts uh
okay data profiling again
cool so data profiling let's say you
know you have missing data now power
query has some ways to do that for us
but it's not necessarily uh things that
you can code
again i want to be able to check my data
check my metadata be able to see what
values are missing how many columns i
have it really work programmatically not
just with the data but with the data
about the data and that's one thing that
i find that excel and a lot of the bi
tools aren't really so great at even
something like oh i have a database and
i want to list all the tables in that
database understand the schema it's not
really any
code generation that you can per say do
uh in a lot of these tools
and then let's go i think i have a
couple more examples here random data
again
i mean what the heck's going on here i
don't know because i can just do this in
one line with r and this is nice right
you have a big data set you want to spot
check
right and this obviously if you're
familiar with machine learning there's a
lot of randomization that goes on there
you got to split your data all that
stuff not only is this really really
hard
but you can't see this randomly so that
you know when your colleague does the
same simulation they're going to get the
same results
and there are some ways around that in
excel but by default that random number
generator in excel uh you can't you
can't set a seed on
okay uh this slide i think is good to
really
understand
that
learning r is an investment of your time
and you have a couple ways when you do
something you can
hack it together manually and sometimes
needs must and right you need to get
something done by the end of the day you
can hack it together in excel
but in the long run
you're gonna save time and you're gonna
win right you spend all this time
you're goofing around you're running
scripts and it doesn't work and your
call you know your boss your colleagues
you're thinking what the heck why can't
they just get the report done uh but lo
and behold you get to that tipping point
and everything's automated you don't
have to do things manually anymore and
you're out of that kind of uh infinite
loop so to speak of just coding things
hacking them together uh in excel and
not to beat up on excel because that can
happen in any program but r
is going to have a lot of tools that are
going to help you get out of that rut
okay
so let's see how we're doing on time oh
yeah one thing i want to do is a
giveaway so we're about halfway through
my
formal remarks and then we can get to
the questions soon
uh
we have a chat i believe i see a lot of
comments so we'll make sure that we kind
of get the conversation kicked off but i
think the first thing i'm gonna do
is
okay i see one from ivan i did say that
it is uh it is sort of reproducible yes
i i fully agree
so yes okay um i have hopefully nobody
saw that i have a few data brain teasers
so what i'm going to do is pull one up
here on the screen
and the first person who
types the right answer in so this is
going to be an image of some kind of
data or statistical concept
if you get the answer
and you type it in the chat you'll get a
copy of the book okay so
in three two one this is gonna go up on
the screen
and actually a little later than that
but whoever gets this right
just type it in the chat try to sound
this out verbally
and and you get to work okay john all
right
congratulations we got a lot of people
maybe that one was too easy
but john uh
send me a message
and
you can
uh get the copy of the book so
congratulations sean and again if you
don't win don't worry because you can
still read it for free so
it's not it's not the end of the world
all right so for the next 15 or so
minutes uh maybe less we're gonna do and
i don't know how much of this will get
through but i just want to show you a
little example of of using r
to conduct some data analysis okay so
i'm going to call this data baseball and
i've split this into
a few steps here okay so you'll find
this we'll we'll navigate to this
together in a minute uh but the idea is
let's say is major league baseball it's
almost baseball season
i want to know is there a relationship
between uh teams payroll
and other
variables right can we use the team
payroll to understand
how much they win
how many people attend right and if
you're a data person you may be thinking
these are dumb questions that's cool but
we can still start here right and and
we'll look at how to do that
uh a few steps so we're going to import
the data
think of this as the little game of
baseball right
bring in the data
we're going to do some basic data
profiling so how many rows how many
columns how many tables et cetera
then we'll analyze the data
visualization i kind of call the short
stop here so we'll get to that um and
generally with r and that's i think
important to understand if you're an
excel user your data generally isn't
going to live in r you're
probably going to get it from some other
place
and that could be a database or an api
or an excel file or wherever
right and then you'll do your work in r
and then you're gonna send it out now
probably for a lot of you that might be
sending out sending it out to excel so
i'll show you a couple ways to do that
there there are some options if you
wanted to you could fully automate your
excel report
and and do that from from r you might
not even probably have to
open excel if you don't want to you
could you could do everything um in our
okay so i'm gonna go
to
here now if you have the binder open
you'll you'll see our studio open and
it'll look something like this
uh i think you'll go to files and you'll
see this data baseball this is rmb for r
markdown now if you're if you're
familiar with um
markdown the idea is we're able to use
plain text characters to to render text
and you'll end up and this is another
cool thing to know you could make a
fully reproducible report here with with
r
and right this looks like something that
you could share around the office no
problem
um okay so we're gonna
work through this and again just to be
cognizant of time
uh i may not go through this line by
line but just to show you kind of what r
is what it does etc okay
so the first thing to understand is
we're going to use a lot of packages
this think of these as like the apps of
our okay so
you gotta get a smartphone it's pretty
cool and it's got some basic utilities
you can make calls and schedule
appointments and stuff like that take
notes etc really a lot of the power
comes in
the apps that you download from the app
store that let you do whatever special
use case or help you do things a little
more productively so that's going to be
the same thing with with r right so
we're going to download apps uh we're
not going to get into the specifics of
how you download them you can read the
book on that but just for the mental
model here you'll download the app
you'll open that app to use it so you'll
see that i've got all sorts of stuff
that we're gonna use here so
uh there's a lot of cool data that you
can find to practice with in r which is
alone a really real blessing
the tidy verse i mentioned a time or two
so this is really a package of packages
we're going to use that a lot to create
visualizations to model our data to do
all those data analysis tasks and then
there's some other ones that i'm going
to use just for maybe i really like a
function that that happens to be in that
package a lot of different ways that you
can use it and then to write to excel
which might be which might be helpful so
you'll see that i'm running this
and everything's being generated down
here in the console i do have in the
book a brief tour of our studio i will
also say that our studio has a lot of
tremendous learning resources and really
the idea of of our studios everything
you need to do your job in ours is here
so there's a reason there are so many
pains and windows but now you'll get
you'll get more familiar with it i would
definitely encourage you early and often
to check the the help window up here
there are some really great cheat sheets
there's also a help tab over here
you can learn more about different
functions packages things like that so i
would say that's another real nice
benefit of using ours just the really
robust documentation and and help uh
specifically uh in our studio
so we're doing that we sent this down to
the console now again this is in a
script and this is in a markdown our
markdown script so i can save this i can
render it later if i want to to make a
nice report that i can show around the
office
so i'm going to bring in my data
and let's see why okay there we go ctrl
shift enter if you want to run these
these chunks is going to be the keyboard
shortcut i believe on windows mac might
be a little different um
but now i'm going to start with
selecting my data visualizing it all
that kind of stuff it's all going to
come down to profiling the data now
what's really nice with with um r
and again to be fair someone mentioned
power query 2 but
there's never going to be a need to like
randomly delete data or hide columns or
any of that messy business that gets
people in a lot of trouble everything's
going to be programmatic so if i have a
data set and i only need four columns
and you can almost kind of read it here
i'm not i'm not going to delete those
other columns that's not a good idea you
want to keep your source data intact
right and then you can make a copy of
that and do what you want to from it and
that's what i'm doing here i'm saying
okay i have a data set i'm going to
select a few columns i'm not going to
hide them i'm not going to delete them
or anything like that and then this
looks pretty nice too i mean aesthetics
matter and i think that our our markdown
understands that
okay so
let's see i'm going to
visual i'm sorry i'm going to
aggregate this data
now again this is kind of like a pivot
table i know somebody had mentioned in
the comments about well how would i do
something like a pivot table in an r
that's basically what i'm doing here so
you're going to see i have a salaries
table okay then you see this funny
little icon here so basically what i'm
doing you think of this as a pipe where
line by line by command
i'm cascading my
output into the next input so i have
salaries i want to group that by your id
and team id so imagine a pivot table and
you're putting those in the rows
sections right and then you need to
aggregate it by something so these are
kind of twin functions in a way so i'm
going to group that by then i'm going to
say okay well i'm at the total salary
for each team
and then i can see what i have there
okay so that would be your pivot table
and
now we can do is is join them so again
if you're using power query if you're
using sql
we have data of different uh from
different tables based on those
relationships we want to put them into
one place
very easy to do here in nr specifically
with the tidy verse
and i'm going to use an inner join as
you'll see
and i have a merged data set there so
now i have
all the data that i need to conduct the
analysis again i don't know how much of
it will get through
but all this stuff will stay up in
perpetuity you want to run it hang
around with it later you're welcome to
do that uh but i have my date my my
teams
i have the variables i want to check out
so now i'm able to
start iterating on on what i'd like to
know about this data and hey maybe you
thought oh actually i wanted to use
these other variables well you didn't
delete it so you're you're welcome to
just iterate on that script and and
you're not losing anything there okay
and another thing uh
just to know
is that you can easily check like i said
the metadata about your data um
what okay in this case it's not really
metadata but you're still able to see
the sum of uh one table versus another
and easily easily compare it i find that
trying to do that kind of on on-the-fly
work in a lot of tools i mean excel is
pretty good at it i'm thinking about
things like power query power bi
they're not really meant to
let you do kind of on the fly
analyses with with your data it's all
based on that relational database
and and writing any kind of function can
get messy pretty quickly
uh with r everything saved in memory
right so i'm able to just
call up anything write a function on it
move on with my work and have this all
saved in a script so that it's easily
shared easily reproduced and and so
forth okay so data profiling let's see
how we're doing i'll give this a few
more minutes and then and then we'll get
to questions and all that uh
summary statistics i'll also say ours r
was really built for
statistics so you you even look at the
official r a r the r project for
statistical computing so a lot of the
things that you want to do related to
statistics are going to be
kind of built in now often you can
augment those things with again these
packages depending on what you're
looking for but
something like i want to get the summary
statistics there it is um
[Music]
a lot of data a lot of packages help you
like i said augment that exploration so
for example
uh i like this skin package this is from
uh our skin functions this is from a
package called skimar i'll make this a
little bit bigger uh but again you know
you could get some of these things in
the data profiler and power query but
it's not necessarily going to be
something that i can just keep in my
script and run to it there's going to be
a lot of pointing and clicking i can't
necessarily easily share the output
right so in this case i can see a lot of
what i want to know about the data
and
things like missing values uh things
like the distribution everything so
you're really able to get a high level
view of the data and then zoom in from
there and and work on what you want to
with it
okay
and i can move this back down
uh descript i like this describe
function this is from a package called
psych this just gives you a little bit
more
meat to those uh descriptive statistics
so if you want to know things like the
range uh the trimmed mean all that right
so a lot of options usually just like in
excel there's almost always
multiple ways to do something it's
probably going to be the case in in our
as well so you can get to know your
favorite packages share them and and
help them you can even support them
because
they're almost all going to be open
source they're taking contributors so
you can join that community help with
the documentation as you get really good
at r you could maybe even push to the
code base so it's pretty cool to know
that all the stuff is being built by
you right um okay so let's see what
we'll do here i know we've got a couple
of minutes
so data visualization is a great one to
know i'm not going to get too much into
into the syntax here
but one thing that i really want you to
see is that if you had like a histogram
in excel
and you wanted to change it to i don't
know a tree map or a bar chart or
something
it would be kind of hard i think you
have to change the chart type and
sometimes your axes get messed up you
want to switch the axes and there's a
lot of pointing and clicking it's hard
to know exactly what happened uh
generally with with what we're doing
here in gg plot and this is another tidy
verse
package
you just have to change a function
change an argument and that's another
thing i try to really point out to excel
users you've used functions a lot
right you've used index you've used
vlookup or xlookup
uh
you've you understand okay well this
function this argument is optional and
this one is required and this has a
default that's the same kind of stuff
we're going to use a lot of functions in
in r so you have like i said in the
description you have a big head start
and this thing may not really look like
much right now but if you break it down
you're seeing okay
well i have a function
and here's an argument
data okay so that's probably where the
data is coming from that makes sense
okay aes that might not make as much
sense right now but let's drill into
that and we see okay x so this is a
chart okay so the x is payroll that
makes sense
and then i don't know about gm but this
has histogram so you're kind of thinking
okay so basically i'm making a histogram
with payroll on the x-axis from data
understandable and again if you wanted
to change something it's very easy in
this case i think i'm just changing my
variable on the x-axis okay so i think
it's 12 30 right now
again you're welcome to run through any
of this on your own
the end product is going to be and let
me actually pull that up in my because i
had already done this
um
okay where is that file
the joys of having a lot of windows open
okay what i wanted to show you is
the
output
that you could get
let's say you wanted to use r and do all
the cool things you learned today but
you still have to put it into excel
because that's what people at work
demand
um
this could be
and again there's the code
for for this in that in that notebook
um
i don't know why it's so slow
okay it's opening just on the other
window okay so
here we go so we have a table
i wrote this from excel
now i'm sorry from r now if you needed
to maybe i don't know make this
formatted and you know add the currency
and all that you could do that in in um
in our so if you're a vba person and
you've worked with kind of
programmatically
formatted columns and things like that
you could add these charts now i put a
chart from ggplot you could build an
excel chart from r as well so again
really anything you needed to do
to build some kind of excel product you
could do it in an r and this is just the
tip of the iceberg right so we only have
so much time and you're saying that i
already
didn't get to show you everything
but like i said you can check it all out
later okay so let me go back to
the slides here i think we'll do a
giveaway in a in a minute here
um okay the other thing and i'll make
sure that this gets and then i'll we'll
move to the questions and discussion and
everything
if you want to
summarize what you've learned today
this is going to be a white paper that i
have it's just a few pages just to learn
about r as an excel user so you can
download that white paper from from my
website
and and we'll get you sent up we'll get
that sent out to you quickly okay so
let me go to
questions
i think okay i think this is good
um
yeah let's
let's have both questions george yeah
that would be great yeah and then we'll
do a giveaway in a bit too awesome thank
you
um i see a few people have put questions
into the chat but just a reminder you
can use slido as well
to either ask anonymously or put your
name it's just easy to
see them all there and organize them
but i see gustavo asked the question
one barrier i've found was translating
terms from excel to r
for example what's the equivalent of a
data frame in excel it'd be nice to have
a kind of like a dictionary or glossary
of terms
yeah it would be good to have a have
that all summarized i do i mean that's
really a foundation of the book is to
translate those structures and functions
from excel into our
and
that's the way we learn things is to
associate
what we already know with things that
we're learning now so it's cool that you
gustavo are thinking in that way that's
gonna make things a lot quicker now as
far as a
cheat sheet or something like that
that's gonna be get added to my to-do
list imminently here however i will say
that the the book does
talk about that right what what would a
vector look like in excel or vice versa
um
what do you do with a pivot table in r
and and so forth so so that that's a
good question with kind of an answer
it's just not as condensed as as you
might be looking for
yeah and if anybody has other resources
too or things that you've found helpful
feel free to put them into the chat too
i see mark um here i'm i'm going to turn
it on to people that unmute themselves
okay
there we go i see mark you mentioned um
for people who primarily use excel to
present tables the gt package really
helps
do you want to add anything there
yeah sure i was just going to say um i
think that
um there's a lot of use cases for
using r that um go beyond just data
analysis
you know just speeding things up and
making your life easier
in other areas and gt is a good example
of that
awesome thank you
jacob i see you had your hand raised
earlier do you want to jump in with a
question
no sorry it was accidentally sorry with
the brewery thank you okay no worries
awesome i see um
mckee
stewart you had asked a question into
the chat would you want to jump in and
ask that live
sure um one of the questions i had and
just as a novice playing around with are
is that
there's an enormous number of packages
it is
i am struggling with finding
which ones i need
and how to look for
a function if i if it's not in a package
i've already got
does that make sense it seems
overwhelming
somebody pointed me in the chat to like
the the crayon webpage
and that's got
i can see where you would somebody would
find that helpful but it's still too
abstract 20 000 packages yeah it's hard
yeah
so
that's my
thought for the day
yeah
um is there a key any particular um
area
that you're looking to do a domain or a
use case or something like that that
might be the first place to start um
mostly looking at financial applications
george
okay
cool so um
r has a pretty sizable
number of
time series related things
i would say that
a lot of the a lot of the
packages and functionality are going to
be built off of some of the the tools
used in in the book so like the first
thing would be going back to our studio
um
the help menu here
check out these cheat sheets
and and get familiar with some of these
maybe not all of them but
d plier ggplot2 right so just learning
the fundamentals because there's
definitely going to be a power curve and
like even in even in my script
most of these probably 80 of these
functions are coming from the same
i don't know
two or three or four packages and then
there's like oh hey i really like this
function and i'm going to call on this
package it could be a little dangerous
to do that because it's just more bloat
to your script but um yeah like get get
really good at
probably a handful of them now the the
cran task views are good
but they are maybe overwhelming because
there's so many of them
um
but yeah get get familiar with with
these basic ones like the tidy verse
right and that's actually more than one
package um and then from there i would
say you can start to specialize in um
and i'm sure our studio has some
resources for finance um
but but that would be my kind of loose
recommendation and if anybody has other
ideas on on what to do with that then
we're happy to hear that too but thanks
for the question yeah no thanks george
i see a lot of great links being shared
in the uh chat too and and i can collect
those together but i feel you on that
sometimes there's also so many different
ways to do the same thing as well
and i
i think something that has been most
helpful for me is when i'm actually
googling how do i do this and i see the
packages that other people were using
for that too
um but right uh i think ryan i see your
hands raised too you want to jump in
yeah i just wanted to add uh i feel your
pain uh my our journey started in 2018
when i decided for my first new year's
resolution in my life i was going to
stop using excel
or google sheets because i saw them as
the same and only do stuff in our so
it's really hard
to go there fast forward four or five
years later i think i would look at it
differently rather than trying to solve
find the technology to solve the problem
what's the problem you're trying to do
in our i think you could think of it as
broken out into different kinds of steps
so there's always you're going to use
packages to bring in data so that would
be like a step right
your this your financial questions is no
good unless you can bring stuff in so
there are definitely some great packages
around that
get to know read r again this comes from
tidy verse so read r-e-i-d-r and then
there's also uh read excel for excel
stuff seeing how we're in here like
those are two great sources there's
other things if you're connecting to
databases and like if you think of it
that way like that's there
like george was saying d plier is going
to be your best friend that's your
that's your toolbox that has your
wrenches your hammers for cleaning up
stuff you're going to do a whole bunch
of manipulation in there that would be
your package and then tidy r would be
another one for a cleaning and then
depending on the analysis right so
that's step one step two is like connect
doing clean in the in the data world we
call that wrangling or munging like
cleaning up kind of stuff your broom and
your your dustband and then there's the
analysis kind of point and like george
said ours got a ton of financial stuff
in there like lots and then you have
your visualization and then you have
your output so if you break it into like
four or five sections connect
cleaning wrangling analysis output then
it's a little bit less daunting to go
through 20 000 packages on cran plus the
internet of like everyone's hosted
github ones
not sure if that helped or if you're
like yeah thanks i've kind of already
done that but like that's how i've kind
of stepped through my thought patterns
what am i trying to do in this section
rather than what are all the packages
that i need to learn
thank you ryan that's really helpful
i see there's a few other anonymous
questions on slido i want to make sure i
get to as well and
one is
excel is reactive so for example output
is automatically updated when input
changes
while r is generally not except with
shiny how do you explain this to excel
users okay
um
yeah
when you have r and and you're you're
storing
the way i i generally demonstrate it is
that
you
in in excel like like was mentioned
you you make one change and everything
triggers so i'll just open up a
spreadsheet and make one reference point
to another point to another and then
change the first one and you see
everything trickle down and i think
everybody has a horror story of that
going wrong so i don't have to
really uh do too much convincing there
uh whereas in in r i'll generally just
store a couple of uh items as objects
and and pretend pretend that we're
putting each of these into a box and
we're naming this box you know my object
or
my string or something like that so this
this object is in
your computer's memory now it's tucked
away it's a box that nobody's gonna open
unless you tell your computer to
and and they're all kind of separate
entities now so that
i i'm not going to make one change here
and it's going to randomly change uh
some other object if you're if i guess
you could still do that given you know
how computers sometimes behave but
that's the general idea is you're right
that it's not the um
not the kind of spaghetti
of all these references so so that's a
good good question um i have some of
those examples i think i have some box
illustrations in the book as well so so
that might be cool to check out but yeah
that is a key kind of mental model um
milestone for getting into this
thanks george
um there's another anonymous question
that says i would like to ask a
hypothetical question can a person
upskill in both r and python
simultaneously
oh yeah so the the big one
okay so
so the book the book talks about from
excel to python and r okay
although you will if you read it r is
the second section right after excel
um because in my opinion and and some
people think differently but uh i think
ours a little easier for excel people to
to get into
uh because like i said it was really
built for statistics and data analysis
everything in excel is built around rows
and columns right that you open it up
and there are rows and columns that you
see and and r is is kind of built the
same way with that data frame that's
been talked about a couple of times um
python not necessarily so much was was
built around the idea of rows and
columns
and that's not a problem that's not to
knock python or anything but it just
takes a little bit more of
a setup
to do that so i think that r is probably
easier for excel people now as far as
the question about learning both i would
again suggest depending on what you want
depending on your time you know
individual results may vary as i always
like to say so there are really a lot a
lot of contingencies but this idea of
the the mental cross training right and
if you're going to learn to do something
in r
try to see if you can refactor it into
python or vice versa
doing something in excel try to do it in
python or r so so i think that kind of
interdisciplinary if you will approach
is great but as far as how to
diversify your learning portfolio it's
like i said it's really an individual
kind of question
[Music]
thank you
um i see um
monoli and apologies if i pronounce your
name wrong you had asked a question
earlier would you want to jump in
live and ask that
and i can um add the ques i can ask the
question but feel free to jump in
and add any more context um but the
question was any recommendations on
resources that teach stats using r as
the tool
oh okay
um
i like the modern dive book
it's a nice
introduction that's pretty
uh compatible with with a lot of what
we've covered today with with r i do a
little bit of
stats teaching in in the book
uh but we start with excel just because
people are familiar with that
and and then reproduce those so if
anybody else has favorite resources for
learning learning stats
you're welcome to let us know but but i
think that that modern dive is a pretty
good start for that
awesome is that um
is it moderndive.com
yeah
okay
cool
and i know a few people had asked me
about the recording if you joined a bit
later and
yes the recording will be shared to the
rstudio youtube and i'll put it on the
meetup page and linkedin and twitter or
wherever you found the meetup too
and i'll try and go through the chat to
save all these awesome links and
recommendations that people have
too
um but just to go
over to a few other questions from slido
i see gustavo you had a question about
building the logic behind the code
would you want to jump in and add some
context to that question
can you hear me yes i can perfectly
thank you uh yeah i mean you know i
think sometimes um
you know some sort of at the beginning
of my learning
path with with switching to r and in
and i don't know if this is my my lack
of of of you know having strong logic
and i think i'm a logical person but um
you know what you know you have to kind
of have uh when you're building the code
you have to know what comes first and
what comes after and then you sort of
build in that structure in your code
um i think we're for better words we're
taught to to kind of react i think
somebody said that earlier in excel you
just kind of do things and you see it
and you and you hide things and you
delete things um but you're now building
a sequence that you sh you know like
you're doing in coding
um and and i think you know i don't know
if i'm under you know explaining myself
right but um i think there is there's a
an order on how you code and what comes
first and after when you're trying to
build your data you know for analysis
and i think that's where sometimes i get
stuck
okay
yeah so um
i think it was ryan was talking about
trying to break it into discrete steps
is is helpful
um
if you're an excel
user than getting familiar with with
power query and
seeing each of your steps again
transformed into discrete
things right that even the idea of
extract transform and load right three
distinct steps
we're getting data from somewhere we're
transforming it and then we're loading
it somewhere else
there's always going to be uh iteration
there's also a really cool
if you read r for data science
there's that tidy workflow and some
people in the audience might know what
i'm talking about where it shows you
each of the steps but then there's the
part in the middle where you're modeling
and you're visualizing and it's really
meant to be iterative
right but but there is there is a
sequence that you follow but there is
going to be some some give and take
there so if anybody knows okay yeah
rachel thanks for that
um so hopefully that was a little
helpful thank you
cool thanks
thank you all for the great questions
too i'm i'm looking over to slido and i
see we've answered everything there but
i i know there's definitely things i've
missed from the zoom chat with some of
the comments
so feel free to raise your hand too and
jump in
i'm curious to hear
from all of you um
of where you are in your learning
journey or also
if you're starting to maybe help teach
other people across your team
what has worked best for you all too
i know a few people are just getting
started even today with joining this
talk so it may be helpful to also
share with each other what has worked
best for just getting started and
resources that were most helpful for you
it sounds like
having that glossary of excel to our
terms would be really useful for us all
i see a few people had mentioned that
yeah good point ryan i see working on a
real work problem
can be really helpful too
what i found like
looking back at my own thoughts and then
also like this past year where i've been
teaching people in our organization
is
no offense to anyone with what i'm about
to say
most our journey seem to be very linear
start here end here and you'll be
perfect and that's just how it works and
you know everyone has 10 hours a day to
learn that like we like we did in high
school and undergrad and stuff like that
whereas in the workforce you're trying
to solve a little tiny problem and it
seems ginormous
like it seems so big
right like when you're first learning so
breaking them down into real problems
and it could be like i i just want to
know how to open r
read in a piece of data
right like so
you know we're supposed to do this get
into functions and all those piece but
breaking them down into small little
things that you're trying to do and not
trying to
have a goal of i'm going to be a
superstar or i'm going to wear a cape
that has a big r on the back of it
that's
you know there are some of those people
in the world i think we know those names
but do we all profess to want to be that
i think it's being able to be really
comfortable and efficient within your
own pieces so breaking it down that way
so in work like what are you trying to
do well i'm trying to bring in this data
and like
change the names so that they're all
capitals
or i want to calculate the average the
mean the max or i want to see a
relationship those little pieces and
breaking them into modular little goals
is really helpful
and
for me when i'm teaching i try to not
use any jargon
any actual names of stuff because that
can be a barrier until people's
confidence comes up and then with
confidence they get the capability and
then they're okay to use terms
it's really helpful ryan
and
also just thinking about
like what is that first big win for you
or like a project that
you maybe can save a bunch of time once
you actually get to doing it in r or
automating something
and i'm wondering if people could share
maybe what those are for them or what
are the areas
or certain projects that you'd recommend
starting with
i don't
have a particular recommendation where
to start but in most of my roles
typically i'd be doing all this etl work
in sql
and then pushing it down to excel
so
in that
environment as a self-taught person you
figure out how to do something
and it's important to build up a bunch
of little chunks like that
that you can remember oh yes one time i
had to do this
and it was in this job stream and then i
can go there and say aha i remember now
so building a bunch of little chunks of
stuff
that you know work
and
you can remember where you put them
to go back and refer to again we'll
speed the process
so it's kind of like where i am now so
i'm just getting started in r so
let's see where this goes
thanks definitely that that's a really
good point
like just being able to reuse your own
code and
being able to find it is very important
too
i see someone else said in to the chat
any regular reporting especially if the
reporting requires copying paste
i'm going through that right now with
making uh
trying to make slides
with r so that i'm not copying and
pasting into google slides
so that every time the data updates i
can just automatically update the slides
yeah good good call out you you can make
a slideshow with with r and the tools
that that we're using today
i didn't do that because
uh it's that trade-off and sometimes
don't don't kill yourself right there's
there's always going to be a trade-off
if you just have to do things once maybe
the sloppy way is okay right it's okay
to make powerpoints depending on what
you're doing if you have a case like
with rachel where the data is going to
update and you don't want things to
break in that then it's probably a good
idea um if you have to copy and paste
like somebody mentioned then yeah think
about automating it but but uh you know
sometimes i think we as tech people want
to just automate everything and that's a
good
that's a good uh instinct to have but it
can it can't backfire at times let's be
honest
so it's definitely taking a lot longer
but i'm hoping that it pays off oh yeah
yeah no it's a it's an awesome tool to
have and and even i i've had i've had
things where uh you know people have
their weekly reporting and they're
copying and pasting out of excel
and uh dumping it into an email or a pdf
or whatever and just i think it's that
art of the possible too right just
knowing that you can
automate it even if you don't know how
to yet
just knowing that you can and having the
aspirations to doing it already puts you
ahead of the majority of your cohort so
that's great
i see um jamika had a great
idea in the chat and you said you'd love
to partner with individuals to work on
small projects and build on real world
projects to build your portfolio
and it looks like quite a few people are
interested in that too so i'm trying to
think what's the best way for us all to
connect here
after the fact and
i was pedro i just read my mind too
that's great the r for data science
slack channel is a great thing resource
um
so maybe we can make a channel
there
to follow up from the meetup and um
just to make it easy to find after the
fact we'll call it excel meetup
i'll reach out to john who runs that
that group
but if anyone's interested in joining
that slack it's
i'll put the link to join
in the chat
um but also before we hit the top of the
hour i also wanted to
introduce a new
working group that we'd like to kick off
um
and for that i'd love to turn it over to
you ryan to introduce it
thanks rachel it just took me a long
time to click those buttons
sorry
thank you everyone for for welcoming me
and allowing me to be here and take a
few minutes of your time um
excel is
is the bane of my existence in
everyone's existence it's actually where
i learned to code like like you said
george ray like you you learn functions
and that kind of stuff it got me on that
path
um i think the superhero in me wants to
turn everyone into an r user and i'm a
fanboy and i see its power
but i do know a little bit of the
reality that not every single user in my
organization current or potentially
future will
probably share the same sentiment that i
do so
thinking through it and like in other
places
what's the goal and in our organization
in our hope the goal is to turn people
into data users and using data to make
informed decision making so getting
getting them to use it and the
likelihood of removing excel is probably
20 plus years away like realistically in
my organization and maybe even more in
others so
at another place at the city of toronto
we we took that on and was like well
let's let's have people go where they're
comfortable and we made something for
google sheets and that's where i'm
talking want to go to is knowing that
excel is
a big part of many people's data life
maybe not individually but
organizationally
i would love to make and have something
that allows people
to gain the power of our with inside of
excel
realistically what could that be um
we've been playing with it and creating
apis and hosting them in connect so that
people can pull data right into excel
so that some of that stuff is already
taken out of the out of the equation and
then also maybe accessing different
models right so if you have models
but currently today it's kind of a pain
right you have to write vba macros and
all these other things to link up to api
so my thought was
is there a chance for a desire or a
thought that people would love to
collaborate work on building an add-in
that connects up where people connect to
data sources for their organization and
pull it in whether you have
uh sorry for the shameless plug or
connect um or or another source of where
you host your data
so i'd love to chat about it i don't
know if that was what you're thinking
rachel but like these are some of the
thoughts to really push r and help out
that transition to a data organization
and maybe another step for users to jump
into the r world
definitely and curious to hear other
people's thoughts too
because i know
also ryan when we talked about it you
mentioned
doesn't have to be someone who
uses r every day if you use excel
every day we want to hear your
perspectives too around what would be
useful
so i did just put a link into the chat
right now
if you'd want to be part of that working
group
you can kind of you can just put your
email and name in there and we can
schedule
a smaller zoom meeting to just chat
about it too and see what what works
best
but
this is always the hard part silence i'm
here to see if somebody wants to jump in
but feel free
if you have other thoughts too or
want to expand on anything ryan said
but again i put that form right there
and
if you want to join that that next call
feel free to just put your email in
there
i know we're getting to the top of the
hour and a few people
mentioned they have to run um
i do want to make sure we also get to
all the questions that you had for
george too and thank you so much george
for an awesome presentation really
appreciate
your time here and sharing with all of
us
sure yeah love to see the people making
connections want to start a group all
that stuff so
uh
that's great to see the community
starting already within an hour
um
i did want to do i picked to get another
winner
so michelle c
congratulations
you want a copy of advancing into
analytics so if you want to let me put
my um
[Music]
let me put my email in the uh
that again
and
just send me a note and we'll get that
sent to you
and the other thing is just for my kind
of wrap up here
i'll put this in the in the chat as well
if you did win a copy
don't fear because you can still you can
still read the book uh yes francis it is
available you can learn a lot more about
the book the chapters where to get it
and so forth at this link
um
amazon
wherever you buy a book you can read it
from the publisher's website you'll find
a link to read it for free so so happy
reading and if you could please leave a
review right because that lets people
know
of its quality
it's again the community helping each
other so all i can ask for for having
attended today is if you choose to read
the book leave a review and and i'll
feel uh like we've had a pretty nice
community building session here so i
think that's everything
from me and i'm happy to
um
answer any more questions
you can find me on linkedin if you'd
like i'll put my
note on in the chat there as well i've
got the website as well you can check
that out where the book is and yeah
thanks thanks again everybody i really
really appreciate everybody's time and
an interest in in the
topic thank you so much george i'm gonna
stop the recording now if anybody wants
to jump in with other questions and
[Music]
you